let's talk about Mar-A-Lago and this is
exactly where there's a disconnect and
where I talk about facts
when I was with the FBI and I would
execute a search warrant if there was a
lawyer that showed up on scene I loved
that why because I would go up to the
lawyer and say hey lawyer I'm looking
for X Y and Z can you talk to your
client because maybe you can make my
life easier and make your clients life
easier because I don't want to tear tear
apart his house I don't want to disrupt
his family I don't want to start ripping
going through draws I'm just looking for
X Y Z and the lawyer inevitably would go
sure agent here's where you need to go
here it is and we would go we'd get it
and leave how often did that happen like
that's a routine but if you did it if
you did 10 10 warrants all the time and
how many times would they say here it is
all the time really if the object was
there it was just a matter of time
because oh God you know listen first of
all when you talk about real search
warrants and you talk about the contents
of the affidavit and support of the
search warrant basically there's
something that's called ripeness meaning
fresh information so someone apparently
had has has reliability and credibility
to attest that they have seen what we're
looking for on that oh God you guys
already know it's there of course and
just like when they got to Mar-A-Lago
this was not by surprise that they that
they didn't know they were going to find
these boxes of documents someone had
already put their eyes on it so they
already knew that they were going to
find it but this idea to wall off or
keep out of lawyers and and the other
thing is if I was an agent I invited
lawyers to be a bird on a perch they
couldn't interfere with the search but I
always liked that because they kept us
honest and they also prevented from
anybody accusing us of misconduct of
either taking something or destroying
something or going into you know
something that may have made us look
unprofessional why would they do it
without a lawyer being there though
that's very weird so my interpretation
in my opinion is because they went in
under the broadest pretext knowing that
they knew exactly where these box boxes
of documents were but they were also
hopeful again the mentality is let's
look everywhere because maybe it's not
necessarily what's described in the
warrant but maybe we'll find other
things maybe related to the January 6th
uh situation or maybe we'll find
something else some other Smoking Gun if
listen here's the thing Patrick if I'm
Donald Trump's lawyer and I show up at
Mar-A-Lago and they give me a copy of
the war and I say okay you guys are
looking for these boxes and these
documents come on in I'm going to walk
you downstairs and say here they are now
you could say Well Mr cap and you know
you could keep documents somewhere else
I'd be like listen let me escort you all
through it but I'm not going to let you
start rifling through things and start
looking at things that are not specified
or articulated within the warrant and
and what I find so offensive is look and
here's where the breach is and here's
where the dishonesty is when you are an
agent and your agent's going to execute
a search warrant there is an operation
plan that is put in place days before
the execution in the search warrant and
there's an operational meeting and the
Rules of Engagement are gone over and so
when you go into someone's house or
someone's office
you don't just grab stuff and throw it
into a box you have to examine what
you're looking at to ensure that you are
legally entitled to take that you can't
just grab documents and throw them in so
how do they but that's the whole point
that's what they did they came in with
like a sweet street sweeper and
collected everything and figured well
we'll go through it later the breaches
and the offense to me is now we know
that there are
indisputable privileged documents
meaning a lawyer a Time attorney-client
privileged documents that in no way
should have ever been seized and if they
were even being considered to have been
taken as a agent I would have addressed
it with Donald Trump's lawyers on scene
and to either make an agreement on
location we're going to take the
documents they're going to go into a
yellow envelope they're going to be
specially marked they're going to go to
a taint agent we will not look at them
and they're going to be segregated but
you see none of that was done and
whether it's one document or two
documents when you have that breach when
you have the violation to me it taints
the Integrity of the overall mission and
it makes you look dishonest so but to be
able to do that that that means
so in FBI there's got to be Democrats
Republicans Independents so right before
they're about to do something they came
from Washington D.C Patrick they were
flown down they had to leave their
phones and they were flown in and then
they were flown out what does that mean
okay so when I would execute when I had
a case that took me let's say I'm down
in Florida and I developed information
that's going to lead to a search up in
Atlanta or New York I'm going to notify
that field office and they're going to
work in concert with me when it comes
time for me to execute that search
warrant I'm not bringing Agents from the
Miami division up to Georgia or up to
New York now as a case agent I will be
there because it's my case but I'm going
to utilize the local FBI office just out
of the economics of it just out of just
the mere Manpower but that's not the
case they used a squad out of FBI
headquarters men and women who were
flown down specifically for this Mission
they did what they did and then they
were flown out and not only that but
they were walled off to communicate with
anybody here why because there was a
concern that either was going to leaked
out or either that someone here would
not be on board with what they were
going to do so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]